an update this afternoon on one of the
teens shot in a drive-by shooting
happened last week in Centennial hills
after suffering critical injuries the
family says he is improving the 14 year
old boy and a 12 year old girl both
injured last Tuesday in a neighborhood
near 95 in Durango the boy's mother now
speaking with 8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha on why she thinks her son
was at the wrong place at the wrong time
14 Jill Cason was playing outside with
his friends when suddenly several
bullets hit him now his mom still
doesn't understand why this happened I'm
hurt from angry because I need answers
answers tequila Pebbles is trying to get
while navigating the worst week of her
life I felt like I died eight minutes of
my son going outside I heard gunshots
Pebble says she ran out knowing someone
was badly hurt only to find her son and
his 12 year old friend shot my son was
literally here
about right in front of this car and I'm
running around here just screaming they
were on the ground trying to grab each
other's hands
to help each other neighbors drove the
teen kids to the hospital it was
uncertain if Kaizen would survive as a
mother to go home to wash all the blood
that was on me off of me and not know if
my child was going to be here in 24
hours
was the worst experience I've ever
experienced in my life Metro Police say
the shooting was gang-related but
Pebbles is confident her son was not the
target he's not a gang member if I felt
like my son was a gang member I would
not be talking to you because then I
would understand where this is coming
from kaisen was shot five times and
miraculously making a recovery I'm
looking at all the holes in my son's
body
and I'm like
how did you survive Pebbles didn't
hesitate when asked if she has anything
to say to the shooter I praise turn
yourself in and I pray for your parents
because I'm a parent that's hurting your
parents were hurt too because you will
be going to jail
so far no arrests in this case but
people's telling Victoria Metro has been
out patrolling the neighborhood every
single day as for the 12 year old that
was also shot she is at home recovering
it's unclear when kaizan will be well
enough to go home